ولكن انتقل لنتابع المجريات على الارض في
اوكرانيا المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ديميتري بيسكوف يقول ان روسيا تريد تحقيق
اهدافها في اوكرانيا وستحققها لكن تغيير
السلطه في كيف ليس هدفا للعمليه العسكريه
التي تجري الان في اوكرانيا
عسكريه جديده وجعل وكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه والعالم الى الضغط على اوكرانيا
لوقف استهدافها محطه
وينضموا الان الينا من ماريو كول مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي امام نيكولايب ينضم
الينا تامر الصمادي اهلا بكما تامر وامين
اذا يهمنا ربا نعرف اخر التطورات هناك
كثير من الحديث في الاروقه السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه عما يجري على الارض ولكن
انتم في قلب الحدث ونبدا معك تامر من ميكو
لايف تفضل
نعم تطورات متسارعه في الحقيقه ليلى على
عدد من الجبهات الجنوبيه هنا في ميكو لايف
كان هنالك قصف متواصل على منطقه اشتوكه
فتابعه لميكو لايف للمدينه ميكولايف
وبتاكيد التطور الابرز والاكبر هو في
زبروجيا القصف والقصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه متواصل منذ صباح هذا
اليوم لكن في منطقه بعيده عن منطقه
المفاعل النووي في زبرجيا عمده ميليتوبيل
هذه المدينه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه في زمولوجيا قال قبل قليل بان
السلطات او القوات الاوكرانيات تمكنت
بالفعل من قصف قاعده عسكريه للقوات
الروسيه في المدينه وايضا
السلطات الاوكرانيه تهامه الجانب الروسي
قصف اثنتين من القرى في منطقه زباروجيا
وكان هنالك قصف مكثف وفقا ل
الجانب الاوكراني يوم امس
للمفاعل او للمحطه لمحطه الطاقه النوويه
في زبروجا وتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات فيما
يخص الفاعل او من يقف وراء هذه او هذا
القصف سلطات الاوكرانيه جددت اتهامها
لموسكو بانها هي من تقوم بقصف تلك المنطقه
وتقول بان هنالك اضرار بالفعل وقعت في
اجزاء من ذلك همم ذلك تلك المحطه دون ان
يؤدي ذلك الى تسرب في الاشعاعات اليوم
وكاله الطاقه الذريه تحدثت عن ان فريق
للوكاله من الخبراء سوف يصل الى
الاضرار وتحدثت عن اكثر من همم يعني قصف
تعرضت له المحطه ودعت الى الابتعاد ابتعاد
الطرفين عن تلك المحطه وقالت انها سوف
تحقق في الامر اتطورات ايضا متلاحقه في
منطقه اخر سون وانا انتظر هذا الهواء
اعلنت قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه عن
تجدد القصف الروسي على عدد من المناطق في
خيرسون وتحدثت ايضا خلال الدقيقه الاخيره
عن ان هنالك جرحى في صفوف المدنيين وايضا
تحدثت عن يعني تغير للقوات او نقل للقوات
الروسيه على طرف نهر دنيبر من الجهه
الشماليه او الجهه اليسرى التي انسحب يعني
هذا ضفه هذا النهار انسحبت اليه القوات
الروسيه التي كانت متواجده في خير سون
تقول السلطات بان القوات كبيره روسيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد تتحدث عن
قوات روسيه كبيره على طرف الضفه اليسرى في
همم نهر دنيبر تقول بانها تعزز من تواجدها
لكنها رصدت ايضا تحركات وانتقال لقوات
روسيه باتجاه المناطق الشرقيه
وتحديدانيات سكولوجان ايضا التطورات
متسارعه على جبهه البحر الاسود وهذا اليوم
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه تحديدا قياده
عمليات الجنوب بانها رصدت ثمانيه من السفن
الروسيه التي وصفتها بالمقاتله وانها تقوم
باعمال عدائيه على طول البحر الاسود وانها
ترصد هذه التحركات عن كتب نعم
همم امين
اما عبد الصمد
والمدن والبلدات المجاوره لها استفاقت
صباح اليوم على دوري قصف قالت السلطات
الموليه لروسيا انه همم تم همم استخدام
المدفعيه الثقيله وايضا صواريخ امريكيه
الصنع من طراز هايمارس من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا وبحسب السلطات تم
استهداف مدينه ماكيفا وايضا حي بتروسكي
اضافه الى بلده بابلوكا التي سيطر عليها
الجيش الروسي قرب محور اوبريدار قبل همم
اقل من اسبوع والحديث عن اصابه ثلاثه
اخر همم
القصف عدل ذلك همم عضو الاداره الروسيه في
منطقه
تحدث عن همم تواصل الدفع بعد عدد كبير من
الدعم العسكري من القوات واليات عسكريه
اوكرانيه الى خطوط التماس تحديدا الى
منطقه همم الى منطقه جوليام بول وايضا
المناطق القريبه من ميليتوبول في مقال هذا
المسؤول الموالي لروسيا انها محاولات
عالميه يبدو لي الجيش الاوكرانيه الذي
يخطط وفقه قوله الى شنه هجوم على محور
ميليتوكل وصولا الى بيرديانسك واذا نظرنا
الى الخريطه عبد الصمد فان هذه المنطقه
همم
سواحل بحر ازوف تقريبا بنحو همم 70 كم
وبالتالي همم يقول الجانب الروسي ان
القوات الاخرانيه تهدف الى قطع الطريق
الذي تعول عليه روسيا كثيرا ولذي يربط
الحدود الروسيه مع اقليم جمباز همم شبه
جزيره القرمو الذي يمر بكل من همم ماريو
حيث نحن وصلنا الى بيرديانس والى شبه
جزيره القرم طبعا ايضا هناك حديث من قبل
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في همم لوكانز
كان القوات الاوك هناك همم تخلت خلال
اليومين الاخيرين عن همم هجوماتها ضد
مواقع الجيش الروسي وباتت الان تدافع فقط
على مواقعها في كل من سوليدار وايضا مدينه
بخموت او ارتيموس كما يطلق عليها الموالين
لروسيا هنا في اقليم جمباز السلطات هناك
ايضا عبد الصمد تحدثت عن مقتل مدنيين
اثنين وجرح واحد همم المدنيين في قصف
صواريخ هاي مارس على مدينه تشيز هذه
المدينه تبعد همم بنحو 40 كم همم غربه همم
لوغانسك ايضا هناك محاولات للهجوم على
المواقع الروسيه بحسب وزاره الدفاع في اخر
تحديث لها همم في محور كريم منايا وصفات
ولكن الوزاره تؤكد بان بانها صدت كل تلك
الهجمات واعاده القوات الاوكرانيه الى
مواقع الاصليه واسطه حديثا ما زال يدور في
الحقيقه حتى الان عبد الصمد عن تواصل
الدفع بالمزيد من القوات سواء من القوات
الذي التي شملها طبعا همم شملتها التعبئه
العامه الاخيره في روسيا او من تلك القوات
التي انسحبت من الضفه اليمنى لنهر نيبر في
خرسون الى هذه المناطق زبروجيا لوغانس
وايضا غدونيسكو هذه المناطق طبعا المرشحه
اللي انت شادها معارك همم عنيفه خلال
الايام الاسابيع المقبله شكرا
صمادي الذي كان على